and we start this noon hour with some
breaking news a lockdown just lifted for
a local high school cheyenne high school
near alexander and simmons had been
under lockdown for a little over an hour
it's where we find christian casadas and
christian do we know what caused all of
this
well heather as you mentioned ccsc
police just confirmed that the lockdown
has been lifted they said that the
details to exactly what caused this
lockdown should be released over the
next couple of hours now take a look
here at a live picture here at the scene
we can tell you that there's a couple of
patrol vehicles still present here on
campus since we pulled up here to
cheyenne high school over an hour ago we
counted at least six patrol cars at the
front entrance since we've been here
we've also seen a few students walk out
now take a look here at some of the
video that our photographer shot he
spotted the k-9 unit walking around the
front of the school ccsd police
confirmed a lockdown to eight news now
around 10 30 this morning with no
further information now we've been
talking to a student on campus who says
teachers kept quiet on the situation and
they try to keep everyone calm as police
did their work now i also spoke to a few
parents who pulled up after getting word
about the situation from their kids now
back out here live again ccsd police
confirmed the lockdown has been lifted
but details on exactly what happened
expected to be released sometime this
afternoon we're live outside cheyenne
high school christian casadas 8 news now